alambres de púas cámaras de vigilancia
puertas metálicas y un escáner de rayos
x son algunos de los elementos de los
nuevos campos cerrados de grecia donde
los migrantes esperarán la respuesta a
sus solicitudes de hacía una idea con la
que el país y la unión europea aseguran
que enfrentarán el hacinamiento y las
pésimas condiciones sanitarias que hay
en los campos de refugiados
por eso estos campamentos ofrecen dichas
oportunidades ofrecen una cocina una
habitación un lugar digno para quedarse
y también ofrecen espacios suficientes
para que todas las autoridades trabajen
y puedan decidir muy rápidamente las
peticiones de cada uno de los
solicitantes de asilo
la nueva instalación está en la isla de
samos y costó más de 50 millones de
dólares financiados por el bloque de los
27 también se están construyendo más
campos cerrados en las islas griegas del
ex bus news de los picos que es donde
tradicionalmente han llegado los
migrantes por la cercanía a turquía
aunque las autoridades dicen que la
seguridad ayudará a reducir la violencia
y el abuso sexual de los campamentos
tradicionales para las organizaciones
humanitarias son cárceles y
este montón de cercas que ven detrás de
mí los niños jugarán detrás de ellas
nuestros pacientes vivirán allí y serán
encarcelados esa es la verdad y europa
con sus decisiones tolera esto los
líderes de la unión europea apoyan esto
y eso tiene que terminar by julie stav
grecia acoge a 42 mil refugiados casi la
mitad de los que había en 2020 y su
intención es frenar una ola de
inmigrantes como la que hubo en 2015